the urging fest datasets library
a quick overview the erginfest datasets
library
is a library that provides an api to
quickly download many public datasets
and pre-process them in this video we'll
explore how to do that
the downloading part is easy with the
load dataset function
you can directly download and cache a
dataset from its identifier on the
dataset up
here we fetch the armor pc data set from
the glue benchmark
which is a data set containing pairs of
sentences where the task is to determine
the paraphrases
the object returned by the load dataset
function is a dataset dict
which is a sort of dictionary containing
each split of our dataset
can access each split by indexing with
its name
this split is then an instance of the
dataset class
with columns here sentence one sentence
two
label an idx and rows
we can access a given element by its
index
the amazing thing about the aging phase
datasets library is that everything is
saved to disk
using upper shower which means that even
if your data set is huge
you won't get out of ram only the
elements you request
are loaded in memory accessing a slice
of your data set is as easy as one
element
the result is then a dictionary with
list of values for each case
here the list of labels the list of
first sentences and the list of second
sentences
the features attribute of a data set
gives us more information about its
columns
in particular we can see here it gives
us the correspondence between the
integers
and names for the labels zero stands for
not equivalent
and one for equivalent to preprocess all
the elements of our data set we need to
tokenize them
have a look at the video pre-processed
sentence pairs for a refresher
but you just have to send the two
sentences to the tokenizer
with some additional keyword arguments
here we indicate a maximum length of 128
and pad inputs shorter than its length
truncate inputs that are longer we put
all of this in the tokenized function
that we can directly apply to all the
splits in our dataset
with the map method as long as the
function returns a dictionary-like
object the map method will add new
columns
as needed or update existing ones
to speed up pre-processing and take
advantage of the fact our tokenizer is
backed by rust
thanks to the erginface tokenizers
library we can process several elements
at the same times in our tokenize
function
using the patch equal true argument
since the tokenizer can handle list of
first sentences list of second sentences
the tokenized function does not need to
change for this
you can also use completely processing
with the map method check out its
documentation
linked below once this is done
we're almost ready for training we just
remove the columns we don't need anymore
with the remove columns method rename
label to labels
since the models from the urging phase
transformers library expect that
and set the output format to a desired
backend torch
tensorflow and empire if needed
we can also generate a short sample of a
dataset using the select method